you will soon be able to see Roman
Colosseum in a new way the fourth and
fifth tiers of the ancient site are
opening to the public for the first time
in 40 years next month
Seth Doane is inside the highest gallery
of the Colosseum in Rome to show us all
the view set good morning good morning
just take a look at this view this
ancient structure is iconic it has been
photographed countless times and last
year more than six million tourists
visited but none of those tourists got
to see it from here
this view may be millennia old but it
has not been seen for four decades
that'll change in November when the top
two tiers of the Colosseum are
officially opened to the public I said a
breathtaking view
Federico Golani is the director of the
archaeological part of the Colosseum the
first level was intended for Senators
vendhya questioned and in the second the
the third was intended for the
intermediate categories and the fourth
and the fifth for pavilions and women
Galani Metis way up about 12 stories 120
feet off the ground in America they
would call these the cheap seats the
cheap seats yes from here women and the
lower classes could barely see the
spectacles unfolding below as far back
is nearly 2,000 years ago there were
mock military battles gladiators
fighting each other and battling animals
brought in from across the Roman Empire
can you give us an idea of what it would
have looked like smelled like sounded
like up here back in ancient Roman times
you have to imagine a shower there
laughs they it was really a mask and as
him over the past few weeks of fortunate
few tourists with reservations have
gotten an unexpected glimpse Liz and
Pete fili were visiting from New Jersey
you're some of the lucky few to get a
sneak peak up here unbelievable we
weren't expecting this we were told the
tour would take us to the third
and to be up on the fifth tier is
amazing it's beautiful
finding the money for this more than 1.5
million dollar restoration took some
time the work all funded by the
government stretched on for about a
decade the money doesn't is not constant
so for example for five years
the government didn't give any because
we have so many monuments there are
indeed so many monuments in this city
and this one is very high up on many
tourists to-do lists and now it is Jeff
a little higher thanks to the assignment
this is pretty good I think there's no
cheap seats when it comes to the
Colosseum in Rome right so we go to Rome
this summer I want to go again